[Musique]
face à la première
bonjour madame bonjour monsieur bonjour
à toutes et mercier de hanau éviter de
nous être de nous avoir rejoint ici de
notre studio de martine première pour
ceux en ce dimanche 25 juin comme disait
thiriez à l'instant les jeunes en
politique c'est le thème de notre
émission vous l'aurez noté la moitié des
candidats aux élections législatives
étaient des novices ou des néophytes en
tout cas beaucoup n'attendaient ne
détenait aucun mandat électif où il
n'avait jamais eu d'expérience
auparavant dans le milieu politique ce
qui n'est pas forcément du car le cas de
nos invités
mais on va se présenter tout à l'heure
et quand on energy l'analyse au niveau
des suppléants de suppliante on voit que
cette proportion de la moitié est
beaucoup plus huppés comme quoi il ya
quelque chose qui a pu se passer durant
ces élections législatives en martinique
avec des fortunes diverses et des
résultats contrastés ces jeunes femmes
et ces jeunes hommes montrent que les
reçoit de s'engager au service du bien
public
ceci dit les jeunes en politique ce
n'est pas nouveau chez nous plusieurs de
nos dirigeants commencé très tôt
l'enfant qu'on politique d'aimé césaire
à michel renard en passant par alfred
marie-jeanne 8 en enlevant la basse
pointe ces trois cas qu'un au macumba
jusqu'à profile au loin
jonny est un joueur à fort de france
pour ne citer que quelques exemples
les jeunes en politique pour en parler
aujourd'hui après la très longue
séquence électorale de ce premier
semestre est au seuil de la nouvelle
législature qui va commencer ce mardi 27
juin quatre jeunes acteurs de notre
scène politique par ordre alphabétique
jérémy ferdinand bonjour bonjour à tous
ceux qui nous écoutent et tous ceux qui
vont nous voir sont internet
voilà qui sont en train de le faire
actuellement donc de mode présentation
briques bref vous allez rectifiées
complétées en cas de besoin 28 ans
formateur agricole exact nous sortent de
formation pour adultes
à rivière-pilote vous êtes originaire de
saint-andrews est implanté et vous avez
été candidat je le rappelle dans la 4e
circonscription celle du sud
investi par nos plats exact tout est
correct voilà et vous êtes militant du
modemas utile de le rappeler également
pour la sono des mains car on affame
éthique toujours johanne gaudreau
bonjour bonjour à tous pour qu'ils lui a
été candidat dans la première
circonscription
1peler celle du centre du centre
atlantique vous êtes âgé de 29 ans
expert immobilier entrepreneurs dans
l'événementiel et vous avez vous êtes le
président fondateur du cercle
démocratique martiniquais c'est bien ça
donc vous allez nous parler de votre
expérience tout à l'heure je pourrais
aussi les retours notables avec indique
marveaux bonjour merci d'être venu vous
aussi vous êtes également âgé de 29 ans
vous êtes chargé de développement
durable à la chambre de métiers et de
l'artisanat des faits et vous avez été
le suppléant de marie-france toul dans
la troisième circonscription celle de
fort de france
vous êtes dans vos militants du ndm le
rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique dirigée par claude lise et
enfin avec nos giovanni williams bonjour
bonjour le plus vieux si j'aurais pu
l'écrire d'éviter vous inquiétez pas je
ne parle pas de moi
31 ans avocat de formation vous êtes le
suppliant de josette manin élu député
dans la première construction du centre
du centre atlantique qui a été lue pour
bâtir le pays martinique qui ensemble
important think nouvelle vous est
implanté au robin où vous êtes
conseiller municipal d'opposition mais
vous même vous ne fait partie d'aucune
formation politique si bien ça et j'ai
32 ans je conclus vu que ce que vous
voulez dire
alors merci messieurs d'être venu
aujourd'hui pour nous parler un peu de
la manière dont vous avez vécu cette
très longue séquence électorale que nous
allons commencer par ça et puis ensuite
voir en seconde partie de l'émission
comment vous voyez la martinique dans
les cinq ans qui viennent
nouvelle période qui entraîne souffle t
on donc nous avons avec une interminable
séquence électorale dix mois d'actualité
politique depuis les primaires de la
droite du centre jusqu au second tour
des élections législatives alors tout
d'abord bon là il ya pas de donald
fabrique indique marc vos voisins
comment vous avez vécu ça comme citoyen
comme militant
engagée alors en tant que citoyen
effectivement je trouve que c'est une
période qui est très long effectivement
on est beaucoup sollicité sur cette
période et je pense que ça peut être
éprouvant pour certains de nos
compatriotes c'est et puis l'électorat
mais c'est une période obligatoire et
aujourd'hui c'est important d'avoir
cette période et élective pour justement
déterminé que des grandes orientations
et le pouvoir est entre les mains
justement du l'électoral donc il faut
bien passer par là j'aurai une ferdinand
appareils votre position votre analyse
ci ou ceux ci l'ont ces dix 10 mois que
l'on colle envieraient parle de semaine
mais en fait là les choses ont commencé
depuis fin août dernier oui
effectivement c'était assez lourd et
pourvoit que la participation des
martiniquais montre aussi la lourdeur de
cette époque mais au-delà de tout ça en
tant que passionné de politique moi
j'étais comblé
en tant que passionné de politique
j'étais comblé de voir pas seulement
sous le plafond c'est mais sur le plan
international nous états unis en
amérique du sud où elle s'était jetée et
socialement intéressé par ce qui se
passe à un aveugle au venezuela
notamment à widnes vernis sur
l'actualité purement française ou non un
candidat hors bilan du très bien et
jovani williams l'a également puisque
vous êtes encore engagé là puisque là
vous avez une responsabilité même si en
la suppliant reste souvent au second
plan
on ne sait jamais ça peut ça peut vous
ouvrir d'autres portes
effectivement la période électorale et
est longue plus de dix mois
on a enchaîné présidentielle puis les
législatives
maintenant c'était une période très
importante obligatoire comme malika bien
le dire mais pour ma part c'était une
période exaltante passionnante et
aussi je suis un peu crevé là
aujourd'hui parce que en période
électorale on bouge énormément
moi pour ma part j'ai perdu trois kilos
je ne sais pas pour mes camarades mais
en tout cas c'était c'était une période
très exaltante surtout quand on aime la
politique
et malheureusement il ya eu ce taux
d'abstention mais je pense que autour de
cette table nous allons faire en sorte
que les choses puissent bouger un jour
ngô de même question comment vous avez
vécu cette longue séquence
présidentielle en fin de primaire de la
droite regard de la gauche élections
présidentielles élections législatives
mais moi c'était doublement long puisque
j'étais sollicité papa l'a privé de la
dette et du centre où j'ai pas forcément
pris position mais que je donne quand
même des conseils à mes amis qui tend
accompagner sur le chemin nationale
après l'élection présidentielle on a
connu de gros changements on a eu de
belles surprises et dernières élections
législatives qui nous a permis de
continuer à être au contact des
martiniquais dans un échange s'est même
si au dépôt de lecture elle en a on est
quand même à la rentrée il n'y a pas cet
échange intense là durant cette longue
période d'élise l'échangé sont intenses
moi ça a permis effectivement de
m'étonner aux maux physiques ce qu'on
doit courir partout on parle des
problèmes on doit on doit aider beaucoup
de personnes et qui sont dans le besoin
et on doit aussi tenir nos équipes pour
suez qui qui sont à la tête des équipes
c'est pas facile il ya des rires des
pleurs des grincements de dents mais
c'est la vie d'une campagne comme j'ai
toujours dit la meilleure école de la
vie souvent c'est je pense la politique
pas de poste qu'on apprend très vite
c'est qu'on peut apprendre en dix ans
sur le plan professionnel alors sur le
plan plus général avant de revenir sur
vos motivations particulières est ce que
les résultats des élections législatives
et surtout présidentielles correspond à
vos attentes à vos espoirs comme citoyen
comme militant à licques marveaux il
faut dire que tu voulais pas vous
approcher un peu du monde il faut dire
que les résultats des présidentielles
enfin ayant suivi
depuis hier on va dire depuis près de
dix ans l'évolution de la politique en
france ne m'étonne pas du tout
effectivement je pense qu'au niveau
après nicolas sarkozy puis françois
hollande
la droite et la gauche n'ayant pas
apporté de solution concrète à la
population les résultats de monsieur mac
ont voulu ne m'étonne pas du tout
donc après c'est vrai que d'un point de
vue personnel je dirais que c'est bien
avant nouvellement d'avoir un jeune
effectivement je m'accroche et jeunes
pour son poste et après il faut voir
aussi sur le développement des idées
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont été avancées et du point
de vue politique et du point de vue
militant jeu quand même je demande quand
même à voir comment les choses vont
évoluer faut dire que quand les choses
sont bonnes on dit que c'est bon quand
c'est pas bon il faut dire que c'est pas
beau donc on verra comment monsieur
maquereaux au vin de ces choses
alors si vous pouvez juste parlé un peu
en face des micros convient de le
rapprocher simplement voilà ce sera bien
mais ainsi jury final je suppose que
vivre orientations politiques modemas
nous peuple a effectivement ça fait 20
ans qu'on en attend encore nous pas
d'accroc pièce mais au-delà de tout ça
on se présente aux élections
législatives pour gagner aussi donc bon
le score est ce qu'il est et je félicite
monsieur jean philippe nolot bout sa
victoire mais les mots matière
d'élection mompati pugens faut que
possible et aussi donc un niveau
alarmant pas forcément satisfait mais je
suis très content pour jean philippe
nolot qu'il soit réélu à son poste de
député concernant les élections
l'élection présidentielle effectivement
je suis avant tout un militant un
militant de la cause martiniquaise sur
le plan écologique le plan social aussi
est de voir l'orientation de mâcon j'ai
une réserve dès le départ et je ne
demande pas qu'avoir je sais que un
certain moment on va devoir se mobiliser
dans la rue pour contester pour
protester sur quels dossiers dentition
divers dossiers notamment celui du code
du travail
aussi les chaussons sont assez
difficiles sont présentés difficilement
pour les travailleurs et balancer les
choses sur ordonnance et impossible
débat démocratique
on ne peut que manifester notre
mécontentement par la mobilisation d'une
année où
la même longueur d'onde alors en deux
temps concernant les présidentielles je
partage tout de même le propos de l'icm
en vo dans le sens où rien coûté la
démocratie a gagné
il fallait en renouvellement maintenant
on ne donne pas ne sommes pas là pour
donner un blanc seing au président de la
république et à son gouvernement
les choses vont commencer
là dès le mois de juillet dès la fin du
mois de juin avec les premières sessions
parlementaires
malheureusement constate qu'il y à déjà
un point sur lequel on tique un petit
peu c'est le fait qu'on passe par des
ordonnances sans passer par ceux qui ont
été élus par le peuple
maintenant nous sommes vigilants nous
serons toujours vigilants quand ce sera
bon dira que c'est très bon et quand on
se sera pas bon dire que ce ne sera pas
bon
concernant les législatives mais n'a pas
écouté bien évidemment je suis je suis
satisfait nous sommes satisfaits du
résultat cela circonscription du centre
à quantique qui était la circonscription
la plus sollicitée la plus ouverte
également
je tiens
sur cette antenne à remercier johan
gaudou parce qu'il a pris ses
responsabilités dans le cadre du
deuxième tour
je tiens à remercier également
l'ensemble des électeurs qui ont porté
leurs suffrages sur josette manin et moi
même le combat était très difficile
maintenant nous avons gagné ces
élections mais le combat commence un
autre combat commence c'est celui du
travail il faut travailler travailler
pour la population josette manin est
parti il est en soi et nous avons déjà
commencé à travailler pour ma part en
tant que suppléant vous posez la
question du suppléant est bien le
suppliant est ce que le titulaire on
veut en faire
ils josette manin souhaite que je
travaille souhaite que je participe
souhaite que je sois au coeur de la
population
un dossier en particulier déjà où s'est
pas encore totalement définis pas en
particulier dans cette campagne nous
avons parlé de beaucoup de choses
nous avons parlé des aidants familiaux
nous avons également parlé de la
jeunesse et ce sont des chantiers que
nous allons que nous allons mettre en
oeuvre très rapidement
je vois que vous venez d'être félicités
je rappelle un pour ceux qui n'ont pas
tout suivi que vous étiez adversaires
vous étiez concurrentes ou concurrents
pour être plus conforme à votre vision
des choses vous étiez concurrent donc
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire 2 2
alors de l'intervention de naissance
d'abord sur l'intervention de vanille il
faut savoir que mon appel au vote
pouilles
vous êtes mal tous valides ne doit pas
être chocolat de vanille depuis un
moment on s'est croisés dans des
réunions à l'époque où j'étais
responsable des jeunes de l'ump
il faut savoir que madame manama lui
petit puisque je suis j'ai fait la
maternelle primaire collège avec son
fils yann donc c'est pas de vous dit non
plus que ce que les madame malin donc du
coup pour moi j'étais dans une logique
je suis conseiller municipal du puy la
matin d'opposition mais moi j'ai un
problème avec le tiers opposition sur ce
que moi j'estime que quand on doit se
poser c'est s'opposer pour que le
territoire qu'on défend avance moi
demain si je veux être tous les matins
entre conseil municipal de la menthe
actuelle j'ai fait en sorte d'avoir with
de travail des dernières règles
donc je commence déjà à travailler dès
maintenant avec la majorité ça me dit je
passe du tout afin d'obtenir certaines
choses pour les administrés de mettre en
place ma politique pour de culture j'ai
déjà mené quelques actions sur le
territoire qui sont favorables
donc j'ai pas de souci à travailler avec
la majorité
j'ai reçu l'appel de philippe edmond
mariette au second trouve aussi mais je
dirai au moment où philippe
malheureusement je te connais pas assez
on appelle eu l'occasion de travailler
ensemble
avant cette élection donc donc j'ai
donné ma parole je vous êtes ce qui est
logique pour moi dans une dynamique de
construction pour le lamentin pour le
territoire où j'ai mis en avant le
projet de câble numérique allait bien il
me semble essentiel de continuer à
travailler avec celles et ceux qui ont
déjà commencé cet élan de
2 d'avancé avec moi alors quoi elle est
un peu plus que la séquence est
politique comme nous venons de vivre
tout à l'heure je vais faire les dents
vous disiez je suis passionné par la
politique vous avez moins de 30 ans ça
n'est pas quelque chose que l'on entend
forcément chez les jeunes
encore que il ya john les jeunes
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce
qui vous passionne d'ailleurs déjà
comment en es tu vois arriver à vous
intéresser ou à vos passionné par la
politique c'est la même question que je
vais poser à chacun autour de la table
non avant tout je suis un militant
écologiste
après mes études je me suis engagé avec
la sopam ans et parce qu'on estime
aujourd'hui que la richesse du pays
essentiellement liée à son écosystème
donc en partant de ce principe
je ne pouvais pas rester les bras
croisés en connaissant les tirer
voyez-les que le monde entier a pour
l'écosystème pas se lamente uniquement
en général donc à partir de ce possible
je me suis engagé parce que je ne suis
pas pas autant de ceux qui parlent de ce
qu'ils n'agissent pas est rentré dans ce
combat c'est quelque chose de politique
oui c'est quelque chose de politique et
j'ai été élevé dans ce lié pratiquement
émotionnel avec la nature ne permet pas
donc je ne me voyais pas non plus rester
les bras croisés
voilà il me faut mangue algérienne mais
pourquoi oui mais moi l'écologie cm non
master d'économie
l'écologisme mois sans d'écologie c'est
une formation universitaire qui vous a
amené pas forcément c'est moins une
éducation car quand c'est mon éducation
qui m'a amené leur cette orientation et
de par mes choix aussi professionnel eh
bien on voit que l'éducation est
primordiale et de pas cette éducation
j'ai choisi un secteur où justin est
important car le secteur agricole aussi
il est peut-être mal vu et m'a loi
présenté parce que on connaît tous notre
histoire avec l'agriculture la can say
say clave âge voilà les parents nous pas
tous les forces et moi maladie les
parents ne met pas forcément les témoins
mais pas telle est forcément nous nous
nous chauffer têtes noires soul et là
c'était mal vu réellement est
aujourd'hui beaucoup de personnes
notamment le président actuel et jean
luc mélenchon soit arrivée qui disait
que la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire est essentiel et en partant
de ce possible c'est quelque chose qu'on
a toujours défendu moi personnellement
le mouvement
politique dans les cages dessus à savoir
nous peuple et le modemas on a toujours
défendu la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire la question de la
souveraineté énergétique et cette
question de souveraineté individuelle au
sikkim est très importante donc à partir
de ce possible
il faut agir il faut agir donc à jour
sur le plan politique
effectivement il faut un mode à pau donc
il faut travailler comme disait juin il
faut travailler travailler sur le
terrain de façon pour que un moment
donné on espère qu'on sera toujours
jeune cotonou à ce mandat mais avoir la
possibilité de travailler de façon pour
aboutir à ce que nous nous avons des
teams magnanou à savoir sur la question
martiniquaise indique m'envoie même
question est qu'est-ce qui vous a amené
à vous intéresser à la chose politique
comme je le disais dans l'introduction
au bien public qu'est ce qui vous motive
est ce qu'il ya un événement déclencheur
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui vous a
montré le chemin guide ou quelqu'un que
vous inspirez un événement il y a je
dirais deux facteurs le premier c'est de
par ma formation effectivement lg des
études j'ai fait des études en sciences
politiques et en droit public notamment
est si vrai que par rapport à mes études
j'ai toujours été amené à m'interroger
sur la question la chose publique
on va dire ça comme ça dont comportement
de l'électorat droit administratif
gestion du bien administratif
c'est une chose à laquelle j'ai des
choses que j'ai côtoyés durant toute ma
scolarité en tout cas universités et il
ya une deuxième chose qui m'a fait me
pencher vers la chose politique c'est de
la situation de la martinique en général
et la situation de sa jeunesse pour vous
dire ayant fait des études j'ai beaucoup
d'amis aussi qu'ils sont partis en
métropole firent leurs études dit que
voulu me disent qu'ils n'ont absolument
aucune envie de rentrer en martinique
parce que le pays ne les intéresse pas
du tout parce que il n'y a pas de
perspective d'avenir on se voit pas
vivre là bas et c'est assez bien les
plages et tout ce qui s'ensuit
mais il n'y a pas d'avenir réel et donc
du coup je me suis vraiment posé la
question moi ça fait depuis d'une fin
2015 que je suis rentré ici et je me
suis vraiment posé la question de savoir
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire changer des
choses pour que les jeunes en martinique
et les jeunes hors du territoire
martiniquais 1 soit intéressé à la
martinique et ça passe effectivement par
le développement du territoire
du coup ces choses qui m'ont fait me
pencher vraiment sur la question
politique et qui ont fait que de flora
l'ofs
de fil en aiguille je suis rentré en
contact avec leur dit m
nous avons travaillé ensemble pour
justement ces dernières législatives
donc on rendre en quelque sorte la
martinique with l'attractive notamment
protéger ces jeunes et puis aussi pour
les gens qui y vivent il faut pas
oublier non plus toute la frange de
population aux jeunes et moins jeunes
qui vise surtout les aînés et des
familles il faut pas oublier non plus
ces gens là qui vivent ici alors j'ai
pas dit oui là vous n'avez pas encore
politique peut-être un peu plus anciens
quoi que vous êtes conseiller municipal
robert de l'opposition certes
qu'est ce qui vous a amené paraît qu
est-ce qu il ya quelque chose qui a un
événement un élément déclencheur ou une
personne ou qu'est ce qui explique qu'on
s'intéresse parce que certains
s'intéressent à la formule 1 d'autres au
football encore intel
enfin que sais-je encore pourquoi 7-6 a
justement fait tout ça à la fois pas que
la politique pour ma peau ma part j'ai
eu un parcours professionnel qui m'a
amené aussi à m'intéresser à la
politique
j'ai fait aussi des études de droit du
droit public je me suis spécialisé dans
cette matière là du coup effectivement
j'étais déjà intéressé par justement
cette gestion
des biens publics par les personnes
publiques pour la population ensuite sur
le plan je vais dire en politique pure
je suis rentré en fin 2012
en martinique j'ai commencé à travailler
j'ai travaillé avec quelqu'un qui est
homo des masses j'ai fait un stage chez
un avocat qui était à l'ump et au et en
2014 j'ai été sollicité par l'union des
fausses robert harting pour être sur la
liste aux municipales
j'ai accepté on m'a dit très clairement
qu'il fallait que je prenne ses
responsabilités cliquez kim yu na kim
qui est dirigé par chantal maignan
j'ai accepté nous avons eu un score très
honorable de plus de 3500 voix
élu de l'opposition ensuite j'ai
continué j'ai continué il y avait les
élections concernant la ctm où j'ai
milité cette fois ci avec ans on peut
augmenter nouvelle nous n'avons pas eu
le résultat escompté mais j'ai quand
même continuer mon travail de conseiller
municipal mon travail de conseiller
communautaire également j'ai toujours
continué et comme disait john on parle
d'opposition nos positions mais il ya
l'opposition systématique ne fait pas
avancer avancer les choses
du coup moi j'ai travaillé on m'a confié
certaines missions malgré le fait que je
sois de l'opposition à la base on m'a
koffi cette admission que ce soit quatre
noms que ce soit la vie de robert j'ai
continué de travailler et puis il ya eu
ces élections législatives où là j'étais
également sollicité pendant son époux
martin nouvelle ceux qui n'ont pas suffi
je vais dire classique qui avait fait on
est venu me chercher
on est venu me chercher j'ai accepté je
me suis pas du fossé et nous avons eu ce
résultat là et je continuerai de
travailler comme élu comme suppléant
et puis par contre l'avenir nous dira ce
qu'est ce qui va arriver
gendreau nouveau aussi c'est un peu ne
disant pas en cours vous êtes conseil
municipal tout en haut le disions au
lamentin c'est une vieille affaire la
peau d'une vieille histoire la politique
et vous oui et conteneurs pose la
question sans fils oui parce que tu te
rappelles du jour où j'ai décidé de
m'engager c'est en 2007 quand il avait
chanté amis qui étaient quand même
content d'être avec les madame sans-gêne
me semble c'est arrivé dans ma cité à
avec mes parents à plat dans le désert
où il est jeune mais tant qu'ils
chantent sur vous et compagnie à l
époque et des bouteilles
mais sinon je dise la chanteuse connue
on va te manquer nous comment on fait de
la politique
en fait on s'est lancés à diourbel les
jeunes venaient à l'ump on va vous
donner
donc on marque à l'ump deux ans après je
me scotto di pascali un changement assez
petit os x n'est pas sale passe de
mignon ce que tu es départementale je me
suis retrouvé à paris où j'ai rencontré
le ballon devant ses juges
jean claude gaudin qui m'a dit petit en
politique
quant au ventre et on frappe trois fois
la porte n'est toi vu la situation
martinique et aux conseillers je te
considérais de mettre directement le
pied dans la porte et en fait c'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est que c'est ce qu'on
a fait après une interview télé 2 toi tu
es une élection aux cantonales on avait
des jeunes qui est candidat à une
élection 2012 où il était candidat avec
une et mattia qu on a fait 1400 voir une
élection municipale et c'est comme ça
qu'on se retrouve à rester sur le
terrain des malgré nous et a essayé de
mettre en place la vision qu'on a pour
la martinique mais pourquoi avoir choisi
la droite l'ump alors souvenu de quoi
j'ai grandi les juges fassent la boîte
et bien levé parce que mes parents sont
des militants de doigt depuis des années
à l'âge de 5 ans j'étais déjà dans les
meetings de piau petit à l'époque de la
boîte de la doua que je traînais dans
les pieds des miguel laventure anglo sur
turbine et compagnon du coup j'étais
habitué avec donc c'est tout
naturellement que que nous sommes entrés
dans les parutions mettant se trouvait
et par la suite
j'ai fait valoir mes idées je me suis
pas forcément sentir à l'aise parce que
je n'étais pas d'accord avec ce que j'ai
appelé le sectarisme politique qui
puisqu'en 2011 et 2012 du certaines rues
proches parce que je faisais venir lors
de réunions publiques des jeunes
d'autres partis politiques ce qui ne
plaisait pas forcément à tout le monde
dit bon mais celui-ci comme ça les
jeunes sont aussi en capacité de faire
valoir nos idées nous avons les moyens
de faire la critique de par nous mêmes
aussi donc on va aussi vous montrer
comme je le dirai tamino 2007 comme on
fait de la politique parce que la
politique n'est pas destiné qu'à une
catégorie de personnes
on va vous montrer que les jeunes
peuvent s'engager peuvent aussi
contribuer à l'élévation du poète
martiniquais
nous sommes si martin premier raid en
face à la première notre émissions
politiques du dimanche avec quatre
jeunes que nous avons aujourd'hui des
jeunes et la politique avec jérémy
ferdinand du modemas et de nos plages ou
un nouveau doute qui vient de s'exprimer
du centre démocratique martiniquais à
l'icm en vo du mdm et jovani williams
qui est le suppléant de la députée
josette manin à leur alignement est ce
qu'on a besoin forcément est-ce qu'il
faut un mandat électif de concret ou le
conserver bon faire de la politique
actuelle n'y at il pas d'autres voies
d'autres manières de s'engager dans la
cité il faut savoir que la politique
c'est pas forcément avant un monde pour
la simple et bonne raison que
aujourd'hui même en n'ayant pas de
mandat on est toujours à mener dans une
formation politique à être en relation
avec les consignes les citoyens et les
administrés il faut savoir que c'est
tous les jours on sur le terrain vous
êtes sous 10 city en passant dans une
cité en passant dans la rue vous
discutez avec les gens vous faites du t1
au fait du porte à porte et la politique
ça se fait tous les jours ça se fait
aujourd'hui maintenant sur les réseaux
sociaux ça se fait partout
donc il faut avant qu'on n'a pas besoin
forcément de mandat pour faire de la
politique est aujourd'hui c'est très
important aussi de sa d'idées de pouvoir
dire aux gens je n'ai pas de mandat
politique
aujourd'hui je suis engagé en politique
et je défends les intérêts de la
martinique parce que je pense que les
gens aussi une mauvaise image du
politique en général et c'est vrai qu'on
entend
où en ce moment avec les cumuls des
mandats les affaires politiques qui s'en
suivent notamment au modem et sam avec
françois bayrou et on se rend compte que
les gens sont un petit peu dégoûté du
politique en général et des mandats
électifs
donc il faut aussi faire comprendre aux
gens que la politique c'est pas que ça
on s'engage même si on est dans une
formation vous avez des militants vous
avez des secrétaires généraux vous avez
dit sur i-télé généraux adjoints
vous avez des chefs de sections vous
avez plein de choses avec des sections
donc il ya plein de moyens de faire la
politique dans un parti politique et
vous avez aussi la possibilité de faire
la politique en tant que tout simplement
association puisqu'il faut pas oublier
que des associations font un énorme
travail ça c'est faut pas les négliger
surtout sur notre territoire on connaît
des difficultés
ce site de société donc il ya plusieurs
moyens après c'est l'implication de tout
un chacun qui fait qu'on fait de la
politique ou pas donc si c'est très
important ça oui jérémie ferdinand est
ce qu'il faut absolument des tenues aux
mandats électifs la question est très
intéressante moi j'ai tendance à
différencier deux choses les élections
et la politique et à certains qui sont
très forts pour gagner des élections
mais qui sont pas politiques du tout se
contentant la question de la gestion
moi j'estime que nos politiques doivent
prendre des responsabilités des
orientations donc une fois qu'on a gagné
les élections il faut faire de la
politique mais pas besoin de gagner des
élections pour faire de la politique
toute la question d'albi au mas pas
exempt la mobilisation qu'a eu la
mobilisation dans laquelle j'étais c'est
de la politique revendiqué sur l'accueil
revendiquer le droit martiniquais de
vivre sainement
c'est de la politique combattre le
chlordécone c'est de la politique donc
des engagements sur les questions
sociétales environnementales sont pas
forcément liés à un modèle rentable
électoralement
non mais la question de la rentabilité
électorale elle devient secondaire pour
moi c'est important se dit content
aujourd'hui pour moi c est ce que ma
petite seo qui vient d'avoir 18 ans va
pouvoir vivre jusqu'à 90 ans et ceux qui
contribuent à montpon aujourd'hui ce qui
compte pour moi c'est que est ce que le
légumes que nous recevons d'ailleurs
est-ce que nous pouvons pas produire ces
légumes c'est ce qui m'intéresse
la question du mode à c'est peut-être
plus mais il faudrait pas que cette ce
mandat nous empêche de faire de la
politique
donc quitte à choisir votre avoir gagné
une élection et permettent à mon peuple
de s'émanciper
la question ne se pose pas pour tous
permettent au top de s'émanciper plutôt
que d'avoir un mode électif simple
opinion mais je vois que vous accusez
c'est mon opinion oui dans la mesure où
à chaque fois quand on quand on passe à
une élection quand les élections sont
terminées
très vite il y à des projections qui se
font sous les prochaines élections
on pense toujours au coude après je le
répète souvent c'est souvent le coup
d'après il ya une élection de lundi
quelqu'un est élu le 20 ans 10 et bill
le mercredi on va penser à une autre
élection derrière on ne fait que de la
politique politicienne ans avant qu'on
me pense qu'aux élections mais on ne
pense pas derrière à la gestion de cette
politique ce avant ce qu'on fait
derrière une fois que les élections sont
terminées qu'est ce qu'on fait si on est
élu qu'est ce qu'on fait si on n'est pas
élu qu'est ce qu'on fait on continue on
continue pas la politique ce n'est pas
que des élections comme ce qui a été dit
c'est aussi c'est tous les jours on la
politique on prend le bus c'est de la
politique c'est un geste politique
on préfère prendre sa voiture où aller à
pied c'est un geste politique parle
d'abus aux mains mais on peut parler
également de 2 avant un téléphone
portable
si je prends une marque ou une autre ça
peut être comme kiss considéré comme un
geste politique
tout est politique et on n'a pas besoin
d'être dans un parti pou faire de la
politique il ya des associations il y à
des groupements de personnes chacun de
son côté à titre individuel également
fait de la politique en mettant un
statut sur les réseaux sociaux en ayant
une prise de position
tout est politique et je disais bien à
l'époque avant la faute est considérée
comme un geste politique
donc la chemise rouge et un geste
et bordeaux d'ailleurs fait plus que
j'aille me ferdinand johanne gaudreau
avec sa belle chemise blanche
c'est la clause de la paix des couilles
convertir nos auditeurs alors pareil est
ce que il faut absolument qu'on soit
dans une écurie le monde et par des gens
actifs est en tout cas dans une équipe
électorale comme le sont les partis
politiques très souvent cynique
également pour résumer son engagement
politique à une élection chassant
l'autre de venir ou pas un étang et les
jeux les toujours répéter si ce qui m'a
souvent causé beaucoup d'ennuis
d'ailleurs c'est l'homme qui doit fioles
partis politiques et par le parti
politique qui doit faire l'homme a
expliqué respecte c'est l'homme l'homme
lui-même ce qu'il veut pour la
martinique qui doit amener son parti
personne qui qui le suivent à à conduire
une vraie destinée pour le pays
il parle le parti politique qui doit
dire à l'homme ce qu'il doit faire
lorsque j'étais dans des partis
traditionnels on voulait m'imposer
ce que je devrais dire lorsque j'ai
invité claude lise au siège de l'ump
fonction un débat sur l'éthique en
politique m'a dit mijoulan tu es fou
lanese la rd congo que ses tarifs
monsieur c'est normal j'estime que ce
monsieur a beaucoup de travail pour pour
la martinique même ce n'est pas
forcément un accord tout ce qu'il fait
mais sa voix il faut savoir tenir en en
politique il faut savoir s'organiser
dans politique et ça c'est pas facile il
ya des candidats aux élections ils
savent c'est connu comme lectorale ils
ne peuvent pas dire aujourd'hui si ils
sont lents à 2020 victoire au pape aux
élections on va pas en politique comme
on va la boutique acheter du pain jeu
désolé c'est un combat sur une mission
lorsque que je fis la manche avec avec
grâce à mal s'agit jérémy j'avais déjà
un peu je pensais que mon lamarti de
quelle marge la marge de préparation
j'ai pensé que c'était comme une marche
que j'allais faire mon travail j'ai fait
le premier jour le deuxième jour j'ai
réfléchi mais parce que j'ai mal aux
pieds eddie bo je veux mieux préparer la
prochaine fois pour pour continuer à
faire valoir ce combat là parce que même
si j'ai une image de doigté et composé
de quelques gouttes ou faisait là c'est
des combats qui doivent se concentrer en
fait les flics qui valent politiques
pour faire avancer la moitié de jouir de
ce que j'ai indiqué très important et je
pense que c'est l'une des forces de
notre génération c'est à dire aller sur
ce qui nous rassemble ment sur les nanos
développe une idée qui est intéressant
c'est la majorité d'idées
au lieu d'aller sur ce qu'anthony sous
les choses qui nous divise
quel que soit le bord politique dans
lequel nous sommes essayons d'aller sur
ce qui nous assomme et sur la question
de des réparations il ya un duo ce
convoi il ya quelque chose qui m'a fait
frissonner c'est le voit que y'a pas il
n'y a pas eu que les camarades du cercle
démocratique étaient présents il ya eu
aussi d'autres candidats aux élections
législatives qui a participé au convoi
pour les réparations et là je me dis
clairement une chose si la démarche est
et authentique la démarche est sincère
c'est une très bonne chose pour
continuer le combat pour les réparations
et j'invite tout le monde à quoi à cette
question des réparations ya participé au
convoi
c'est comme je le dis toujours et c'est
seule la mobilisation qui fait les
avancées de deux sociétés
on a on habite chez des gens à rester
dans des clivages gauche droite centre
et sert extrême droite extrême gauche
aujourd'hui je pense que il faut vivre
dans la pluralité séduit notamment menti
on a une pluralité de bons politiques et
il faut composer avec et je pense qu'au
niveau de la jeunesse c'est sous tout
aussi ses combats ses combats de coqs à
répétition entre il ya effectivement
quand on est dans une campagne on oppose
ses idées on ne peut résister c'est
normal qu'ils aient eu une opposition
qui une adversité
mais je pense que je suis aussi
autrement il faut savoir aussi se
rassemblent et ça c'est important
est ce que par exemple le schéma actuel
de gouverne
de la simple et de martinique de la
collectivité territoriale où on a une
majorité très composite de laquelle on
trouve des gens partir de la
souveraineté de l'indépendance nationale
d'autre du statu quo des gens de 10 de
droite dit de gauche
est ce que ça vous convient ce que c'est
vers ça qu'il faudrait aller alors je
pense que dans une certaine mesure il
faut arriver à ça pour certaines pour
certaines pour certaines élections
effectivement on a bien senti le besoin
de la population d'avoir cette alliance
aujourd'hui au sein cet accord de
gestion au sein de l'assemblée
territoriale
je pense que c'était quelque chose de
nécessaire afin de faire évoluer la
chose surtout quand on est dans une une
collectivité qui effectivement ne
favorisait pas la base le partage des
pouvoirs entre les différents partis et
je pense qu'au niveau du grand ensemble
et il ya cette chose qui a qui s'est
mise en place
et justement cet accord de gestion
permet d'avoir une pluralité de
représentation à l'assemblée
johnny ferdinand n'est pas du tout
d'accord je suis en fait sortir du
clivage partisan si intéressant mais à
condition que cela soit sous des bassins
c'est à dire que ça ne soit pas un coup
électoral
je suis désolé sur la question des
assimilationniste de droite sur la des
personnes qui ont soutenu pas qui ont
soutenu sarkozy bon et avec des
personnes et sarkozy qui appelle à
parler de de colo a fait 2-2 du rôle
positif de la colonisation
sarkozy aussi qui a parlé de l'homme
africain qui n'est pas suffisamment
entré dans l'histoire
donc si cette démarche est sincère
annoncions une majorité comme une
majorité d'idées communes si elle est
sincère avec une orientation claire oui
ça peut être positif mais si la question
électorale
non ça n'est pas et aujourd'hui avec du
recul on se demande où est le tcsp par
exemple avec doit aucune on se demande
où sont les dossiers qui ont été bloqués
avec du recul on se demande est ce que
la 7e fonctionne bien donc je suis
d'accord aussi le principe même de la
majorité d'idées mais à condition
qu'elle soit sincère et nos électeurs
ils se voient un programme de travail il
faut il faut à mon sens il ya il faut
qu'il y ait deux
l'idéologie on n'en parle pas assez à
mon sens l'idéologie politique
effectivement il ya des alliances de
gestion qui se font mais à mon sens la
martinique une société c'est plus que ça
il faut une idéologie derrière mettre
des panneaux photovoltaïques en
s'accaparant par exemple des terrains
d'école c'est une idéologie politique
ça vient d'une idéologie politique
mettre des panneaux photovoltaïques sur
des toitures et de biens publics c'est
une idée ou d'une idéologie politique
bien que le résultat serait le même
c'est-à-dire produire produire de
l'énergie
donc tout ça vient d'une idéologie
politique à mon sens on essaye de goût
mais je ne suis pas pour qu'on gomme la
droite et la gauche
il ya des sensibilités de droite de
gauche
pour ma part ma sensibilité plus de
gauche très clairement et maintenant il
faut c'est que ça ça veut dire être de
gauche odeurs ce sont les bases de
solidarité ce sont des bases aux deux
par deux le parentage ce sont ces bases
là ce sont ces bases là qui font de moi
à mon sens ce que je pense être plus de
ce côté là que d'être de notre côté
maintenant je ne dis pas que notre côté
il y que que les choses ne sont pas
bonnes je dis simplement qu'il ya une
idéologie derrière il ya une part il a
une pensée et de cette pensée va
permettre de traduire bien chemin et ce
chemin là c'est un chemin politique pour
pouvoir faire avancer les choses et
c'est pour ça que on constate que
parfois quand il y à des âges des
alliances qui se font alors qu'il y a
des bons je veux pas dire extrême mais
des sensibilités vraiment différente on
constate que même dans la gestion bien
les choses ne vont pas et dans
l'histoire martiniquaise aussi penser à
la go par exemple dans l'histoire
martiniquaise à chaque fois que la
droite s'est associé à la gauche ça
s'est mal terminée vous pouvoir les deux
joseph la rose et joseph la ville avait
fait l'alliance capitale la travaille
avec
fernand terre notamment dans
l'entre-deux-guerres il ya quelques
dizaines d'années mais ça a été ça a été
reproduit avec guy lordinot il ya un an
plaisir j'ai besoin de 1990 ça n'avait
pas donné plus de résultats tous ceux
qui me fait dire oui j'ai aussi que j'ai
choqué beaucoup de personnes comme
durant la campagne ici pas les dugongs
ensemble on pourra payer encore ils
s'affaiblissent sas a illustré cette
originale via le net
j'estime qu'en politique même si on veut
se positionner au dessus des clivages il
faut avoir un discours sincère s'était
pas le cas non pas du tout je prends
l'exemple j'ai été j'ai commencé la
politique avec nicolas sarkozy
j'ai même été ou à présent temps de
génération sarkozy qu'en sa cause il
disait de conduite j'ai toujours dit
clairement ici que ça qu'on dit des
conneries et 7 mon avertissement au sein
de la majorité présidentielle n'a permis
de comprendre que les ministres et les
terres sony qui sont acteurs publics ne
connaissent pas véritablement et les des
problématiques de nos territoires et
c'est pour ça que je fréquenterai des
jeunes du rdr des jeunes du mouvement
des jeunes du ppm ça n'a pas été compris
tant pis en tout cas aujourd'hui avec
les jeunes et qui qui forment le cercle
démocratique de la martinique et moi
nous savons ce que vous nous voulons
pour la martinique c l'élévation du
pornicais pour amener notre peuple ce
qui doit être sa coupe destinée qui est
notre détermination pour nous c'est ça
qu'on soit d'accord au concours de la
corse et le groupe de touche
actuellement pour celles qui viennent là
je suis de gauche
ce que je veux dire par là si vous êtes
pour moi le clivage droite gauche n'a
aucun sens parce que lorsqu'un militant
se met véritablement tout le terrain
pour aider ces populations
en fait toutes les valeurs de droite et
de gauche se gomment parce qu'on est
obligé de répondre en fait aux attentes
de la place on peut importe la personne
qui vient nous appeler en aide et c'est
ce qui est important
le clivage effectivement cantonnée sous
le tien
disparaît au fur et à mesure mais sur la
question de des idéologies cela question
de l'idéologie sur la question de
l'orientation
on aborde les choses différemment je
vais prendre un exemple le des
dirigeants de la 7e avaient pour projet
de faire un grand pont qui traverse la
mer des caraïbes et on a parlé de la
question de la durabilité moi je me
disais clairement que pour nous en tant
qu'écologiste l'idéal ce serait de ne
pas fuir ce pont pour lui en tant qu
homme de droite
sa fibre écologique ce serait de mettre
des panneaux photovoltaïques sur exemple
on qu'ils allaient qui allait éradiquer
tout tout tout l'écosystème marin de
cette zone c'était pour doubler la
traversée de l'aï et le rappel il s'agit
de vienne le plaisir en l'occurrence qui
a ce qui revêt ce projet du voilà
exactement à louis exactement et moi
j'ai toujours tendance à dire que le
problème en martinique ce n'est pas une
question économique ce n'est pas le
problème en martinique et identité moi
je dis que c'est de la li na tion
identitaire ce que ce candidat dit
prenez exemple sur sur la la réunion oui
mais la réunion si près d'un million
d'habitants quand même la réunion si
cela vaut mieux ça n'a rien à voir avec
la martinique donc se dit à un moment
donné il faut être martinique est fou et
martiniquais est pensée économique
martiniquaise penser développement
martinique est avant tout cru les
nouvelles un nouvel écosystème
économique pour nos territoires et les
territoires a dit non mais tu joue
gauche parce que si je joins qui viendra
tibet de la chine
de toutes les façons je pense que
possible autour de la table on le monde
bien on est capable aujourd'hui d'avoir
un discours d'avant un échange tout à
fait construit entre différents partis
politiques différents bords politiques
et je pense que vous dis c'est à ça
qu'il faudrait aussi d'arriver entre
notamment les différents jeunes n'est
pas anti ya cette chose alors il ya une
question qui peut qui va vous embêter
siro quand je vous la pose c'est quel
malgré tout votre investissement là on
entend à vos idées qui peuvent être
relativement nouvelle et novatrice pour
pour une bonne partie de la population
il reste que c'était ces élections
législatives auxquelles vous avez
participé activement vous avez laissé
des nuits sans sommeil ou des kilos
où là il ya une abstention faramineuses
un record historique dont les trois
quarts de la population des trois quarts
des électeurs ne se sont pas déplacés
ils ont regardé des élections comme
c'était une partie décidément film voilà
ce que les gens ne sont pas sortis voter
c'est mon oreille dit est-ce que ce
n'est pas frustrant rageant de voir
l'énergie dépensée les idées que vous
professez et puis bon finalement même
s'il ya eu des élections c'est grâce à
mes trois personnes sur quatre ne se
sont pas sentis impliqués john williams
vraiment effectivement c'est peut être
rageant mais ça se comprend
ça se comprend parce que quand on voit
le paysage politique de ces trente
dernières années
on peut comprendre que le lecteur ne
souhaite pas se déplacer il se dit ce
sont toujours les mêmes
ou alors c'est toujours la même chose
ils promettent beaucoup de choses il ya
la feuille de fond et ils font du zonage
politique
un jour ils sont avec un jour ils sont
contre
je peux comprendre ça c'est à nous c'est
à nous aussi nous nouvelle génération de
mettre des bases différentes de mettre
sur pied dans la fourmilière par les
deux pieds dans la pente
effectivement avant de rentrer si on
veut pas nous laisser rentrer nous
allons entrer par la fenêtre et puis
pouvoir ou vieux la maison et je pense
que avec cette nouvelle génération là
pourquoi que même si nous sommes faisons
partie de nouvelle génération
je ne veux pas dire que tout les jeunes
gens qu'il a tout les jeunes loups qui
cadre politique et opaque à répéter ça
sent les autres langues a fait aussi
donc c'est à nous de faire en sorte
qu'on puisse et bien fait en sorte que
les élections se déplace et confiance de
nouveau c'est pas un autre discours par
notre façon de voir les choses
bien que le ndm par exemple certainement
face de moi je connais pas à l'icm et je
n'ai rien contre lui même si
politiquement il y a des différences le
modemas également sur le démocratique
peut-être mais on arrive à parler à
discuter et puis quand les élections
arrivent effectivement nous sommes non
pas des adversaires mais nous sommes des
adversaires simplement des adversaires
et quand il faut travailler bien nous
travaillons c'est ce à quoi on doit on
doit inspirer et je pense qu'on va y
arriver un jour à 1 go de même mes
questions cette montée de l'abstention 7
semble ans d'indifférence parce que ce
n'est pas forcément la différence
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire ça inspire
un mal être au sein de l'ast immense
nicaise et qui nous oblige nous
politiques à faire la politique
différemment a essayé de mulhouse
exprimé de de muguet pour nous attendent
leur population de faire en sorte que la
population propose est en fait le
politique dispose de lévis et j'estime
que c'est essentiel et faut prendre
exemple lorsque j'ai appelé à voter pour
josette manin tous venus williams j'ai
envoyé un mois de sa part josette manin
parce que oui la voix de sa peau si je
vous disais je vous êtes j'ai pas fait
qu'appeler à voter pour toi on va devoir
clairement travailler ensemble sur
l'ensemble des projets qui relatifs à la
finance martiniquaise aux deux grands
économies allemande et joie n'y a pas de
souci donc donc je sais que je pouvais
travailler que et j'estime que avec
l'ensemble des 18 et monica on doit dans
cette logique et si vous saviez pas les
ponts dans la campagne de la
dynamisation de l'intergroupe
parlementaire d outre-mer alors pour
contrecarrer les autres candidats
reparler de groupe outremer à
l'assemblée et au sénat mais moi qui ai
travaillé auprès de la majorité
présidentielle de 2010 à 2012
je connais la force de cette association
qui est aux côtés du pinet république
effectivement un souffle sur le plan des
valeurs on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec emmanuel navon mais si on veut
véritablement faire avancer des dossiers
complémentaires
il faut savoir lui faire comprendre on
n'est pas d'accord avec toi mais écoute
moi il ya çà çà çà çà çà on fait quoi le
même question pour a dit comment vous
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire cette
forte abstention l'avons également je
rappelle vous étiez là supplée le
suppléant de paris font stool dans la
circonscription de fort de france c'est
quand même frustrant devant que
finalement les électeurs ne se déplace
pas alors que reese ci avait pourront
quand même prêté une oreille attentive
on le suppose pendant toute la campagne
il faut savoir que comme le disait john
ça ça fait partie du jeu c'est à dire
que si on ne répond pas aux demandes de
la population
la population ne va pas se déplacer
c'est comme lorsque vous allez au
supermarché si vous avez un produit qui
vous plaît pas vous l'achetez pas là bas
c'est la même chose que moi de faire la
comparaison entre l'électorat et et le
commercial et le marketing mais c'est ça
aujourd'hui quand vous vous offriez en
politique 6 nov
ou que vous emmenez vos gens si ça ne
plaît pas aux gens ne répondent pas il
faut changer la façon de faire de la
politique
tout simplement c'est à dire que ça fait
des années qu'on fonctionne en prise de
parole voiture no
etc on tourne exc il faut changer des
choses c'est à dire qu'il ya des
nouveaux moyens de toucher des gens par
les réseaux sociaux il ya d'autres
moyens de faire je dis pas qu'il faut
arrêter des voitures sono les prises de
parole les réunions etc
ça fait partie de la chose défection il
faut discuter avec les gens mais il ya
d'autres choses à construire parce que
la société a évolué mais la politique
n'avait évolué avec la société
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas plus
profond que ça gemini ferdinand oui je
pense que c'est bien plus profond ça
ad'ailleurs jeu bon je me permets quand
même j'aime pas trop ce rapport avec
l'électorat
moi je préfère parler du peuple
martiniquais parce que là on y est nous
sommes amenés au mode navre des
responsabilités pour avoir pour
permettre à ce peuple martiniquais de
s'émanciper dans les meilleurs des cas
donc j'ai du mal à aborder la chose en
tant qu'électeur voit la différence
comme mettre les électeurs ce sont les
oui vous voyez j'ai dû lui faire les
électorale avoir cette approche doit
avoir avoir cette approche de
l'électorat s'est retiré toute la
connotation toute cette connotation
humaniste en fait ce dieu que devant
nous on a des êtres humains qui ont des
besoins et six mois par rapport à leurs
besoins qui ne se transforme pas un
électorat voiliers et en partant de là
je pense qu'il faut revoir les choses il
serait paradoxal et je suis d'accord sur
la question de sueur de la politique
d'ailleurs je pense que nous dans la
mesure où nous avions pas forcément les
goûts moyens on a surtout orienter notre
campagne sur les réseaux sociaux sous le
porte à porte
moi j'avais pas de voiture sono pour une
raison en tant qu'écologiste je vais me
voyais mal à 10 une pollution sonore
j'ai pas fait de caravanes parce que en
tant qu'écologiste je me voyais mal
polluées sur cette chose mais le
résultat est là sur ce qu'ils ont fait
qu'ils ont gagné le résultat est là même
si avec un taux de participation aussi
bas ce sont ceux qui ont montré qu'ils
ont gagné il faut pas oublier une chose
c'est que en ce qu on y glisse souvent
c'est que en politique les gens ne
votent pas forcément pour des idées mais
votre point exactement les souvent à ce
jeu là c'est celui qui est le plus court
de danse alors
l'approché du terme de l'émission
vraiment un dernier tour de table
messieurs parce que là il sera bientôt
13e pour le journal de la mi journée
c'est une question que je vous pose qui
m'a été inspiré par lauriane grâce à
mika une de nos conseils journalistes de
la rédaction radio de martini première
et qui vous demande où vous voyez vous
dans quinze ans un petit défaut de
projection vers l'avenir
on commence par à cinkassé difficile sur
15 ans effectivement en tant que jeune
en défendent a du mal à se projeter au
lendemain mais c'est vrai que pendant
qu'elles ont pourquoi pas continuer déjà
à travailler en tant que chargé de
mission donc de développement durable
moi je le fais ou auprès des entreprises
à améliorer la situation écologique
continuer à accompagner les entreprises
dans cette démarche et quelle que soit
la forme
et puis dans mon engagement politique
effectivement voir une martinique
beaucoup plus dynamique dont continuent
à user pour que la martinique soit
beaucoup plus dynamique qu'on répond aux
problématiques des jeunes qu'on réponde
aux problématiques de développement
numérique économique etc à tous tout ce
qui s'en suit donc effectivement
continuer à faire ce travail à faire
c'est fort justement ça du rassemblement
démocratique pour la martinique est avec
l'équipe qui la composent et puis
effectivement on verra en fonction des
élections et des choses qui ce qui se
profile les instances heures et l'union
et on verra comment évolueront les
chaussures les années à venir
le jury le ferdinand moi c'est pas
difficile et je suis un militaire
le militantisme on sait quand ça
commence on sait jamais quand ça se
termine donc je serai toujours un
militant et je vais oeuvrer pour la
cause martiniquaise sur le plan social
sur le plan économique sur le plan
écologique
c'est ce qui m'anime sur le plan
agricole aussi j'espère j'adore mon
métier je suis formateur et du col
j'enseigne à diffuser la culture comment
bien gérer l'entreprise sur le plan
économique sur le plan technique
sur le plan marketing
j'adore mon métier j'espère le faire
dans 15 ans je ne suis pas un
carriériste 1 j'espère le fjord à 15,1
et surtout jouer pour l'émancipation du
peuple martiniquais surtout jure année
où il ya même question sur le plan
professionnel j'espère pouvoir continuer
mon activité parce que tant qu'avocat
les choses ne sont pas faciles du tout
mon ça fait quatre ans que je suis
avocat et
la profession est en difficulté donc moi
j'espère toujours pouvoir exercer ce
métier que j'aime vraiment sur le plan
politique mais à goûter j'espère pouvoir
continuer continuer d'oeuvrer pour cette
émancipation de mon peuple
l'émancipation du peuple a indiqué que
ce soit sur le plan économique sur le
plan social même sur le plan culturel
sur le plan environnemental également
donc j'espère toujours continuer à
oeuvrer pour mon peuple martiniquais et
si je dois singulariser les choses pour
ma commune européenne
merci je vous remercie et johanne
gaudreau enfin même question de présents
comme mon mari sur le plan politique que
ce soit militant maire ministre de la
république
cet objectif qui est de jouer à
l'élévation du poète martiniquais comme
les collègues qui sont 6,7
oui président nous avons peut-être
future gare de même un futur président
vous n'avez pas dit quel public
5e premier à l'iss en eau 15 ans on
serait vraiment forts d'ambitions sans
raison mais bon si jamais respirer on
aboutit au point mort merci beaucoup
d'avoir participé à notre mission donc
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui nous
l'émission est estimé aux jeunes est un
politique avec je vais me ferdinand de
nos peuples à johan gaudou du cercle
démocratique martiniquais a dit que
marveaux du rdm et jovani williams de
suppléant de la députée
josette manin dans quelques instants ce
sera le journal de la mi journée que
vous sera présenté par christine cuppitt
l'émission a aujourd'hui été réalisée
par claudine était le biais nous nous
retrouverons bientôt
bon appétit
face à la première
[Musique]